Asalam alalayikum. My name is Liban. I'm
a student of knowledge at this moment of
time. My question is what's the best way
to explain the concept of which is the
oneness of Allah to a person from a
non-Muslim
background because the question that
what is the best way of explaining the
concept
of to a person who is a non-Muslim
background. First I'd like to know what
is his background. Is he a Christian? Is
he a Hindu? Is he a pari? So based on
the verse of the Quran of Surah Imran 3
verse number 64 which I'll be dealing
tomorrow. Tomorrow my topic is religion
in the right perspective talking about
the concept of God in the major world
religions. Allah
says, "Oh people of the
book, come to common terms as us and
which is the first term?
Allah that we worship none but
Allah that we associate to partners with
him that we erect not among ourselves
lords and pray to others in Allah if
then they turn back bear
witness that we are bowing a will to
Allah subhana wa tala. So the best is if
you want to talk about the concept of
God the best surah is surah chapter
number 112 verse number one to four
which
says says Allah one and only Allah Allah
the absolute
eternal he begets not nor is he
begotten there's nothing like him this
is a four definition any person say so
and so candidate is god you put your
candidate to the test of surah class. If
he passes, we have no objection in
accepting him as God. If he fails, we
don't accept him. And if he's a Bible,
then you quote from the
Bible. If he's a Christian, you quote
from the Christian the verses of which
I'll do tomorrow. If he's a Hindu, you
quote the verses of Tohit from the
Vedas, from the Upanishad, from the
Bhagat
Gita. If he's a Jew, you can quote from
the Talmud.
If he is a pari you can quote from the
Aista if he is a sick then you quote
from guru grans and there's another talk
I've given concept of god in the major
world religion so if you see that video
and if he's an atheist there's a talk of
mine does god exist you see that and
inshallah it will give you a great deal
of knowledge how to deal with the
non-Muslim shakah